Its drawing style is pop at a glance,
so you might wonder it's an anime for children.
I've finally made up my mind and watched it.
Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
The anime I'm going to introduce this time is
THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL.
You can watch various anime on Netflix,
but this anime stands out even among them.
Its drawing style is pop at a glance,
so you might wonder it's an anime for children.
THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL has been streaming
exclusively on Netflix since April 2020,
It isn't very well-known in Japan,
but everyone who watched it praise it highly.
A crazy anime,
a visual hallucinogen,
and a visual meditation are what people call it.
I've been wanting to watch it someday,
and I've been too scared to watch it,
but I've finally made up my mind and watched it.
Well then, let's start the introduction to the anime.
First, I'll tell you what THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL is as an anime.
There are two people we must mention when we talk about this anime.
The first one is the director, who is also known for producing ADVENTURE TIME,
Director Pendleton Ward.
The other person is comedian, Mr. Duncan Trussell.
Actually, THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL
comes from Mr. Duncan's podcast interview collection,
DUNCAN TRUSSELL FAMILY HOUR,
and it was animated by Director Ward's suggestion.
The protagonist, Clancy, is played by Mr. Duncan himself.
This is the anime's abstract.
Clancy is a spacecaster,
and he travels to various parallel worlds by a simulator.
He interviews people he meets at his destination,
and streams it to the whole universe.
When he goes to a parallel world,
he uses an avatar that matches the world.
Maybe this is a little similar to a VTuber.
To put it simply,
he dives into a virtual world like a VTuber,
and streams his interview live at his destination. It's something like that.
The plot is a little like sci-fi,
but the content of the interviews in the anime
is adopted directly from the actual podcast interviews done by Mr. Duncan.
The interviewees featured as guests included a psychiatrist,
a former death row inmate, and so on,
so the conversations and themes are very profound.
Let me think.
At first, I watched this anime without any prior knowledge,
and I thought, "They go on and on."
That first impression was strong.
The first episode was about zombies.
The world is being invaded by zombies,
everyone around them is dropping dead,
but their conversation goes on and on.
After that, I looked up various things.
I found that it was actually a podcast interview,
and the anime was produced to match the podcast audio source.
After I learned this piece of information, it became easier to accept it,
and I was able to enjoy it.
I left an impression upon me.
My favorite character is
the protagonist's pet, a dog called Charlotte, in episode one.
The belly of the dog, Charlotte, is a blackhole,
and it sucks in various things.
Clancy brought her home and keeps her as a pet,
I thought it was cute.
There isn't any particular dialogue I remember very well, but very often,
they come to the conclusion that it's important to live in the moment.
It's no use looking back at what happened in the past,
and it's no use worrying about the future,
so it's the best to enjoy the present.
It's their conclusion.
It makes me want to think so myself.
In the anime, there are also fascinating
and deep conversations you can't often hear as well,
so when you watch the anime,
why don't you set off for a trip to explore the dazzling world of the mind?
I have given you an introduction of THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL this time.
It is an anime,
but it really is an unparalleled, very unique anime.
I have watched many anime already,
but I had no idea such an anime existed in the world.
It even made me sense new possibilities of anime.
We can't help but watch only the anime of the genre we like,
but if you're even a bit interested in watching
an anime you've never watched before,
then go and search "THE MIDNIGHT GOSPEL" on Netflix at once.
It'll make me happy if you tell me what you think
in the comments section or on Twitter.
Let's meet again in the next video.
See you!